[Musique]
bonjour à tous nouvelle édition du 7 8
dossiers ce mois ci je vous propose de
vous envoler direction le bourget pour
le salon international de l'aéronautique
et de l'espace
[Musique]
ce
un rendez vous incontournable pour saint
quentin en yvelines
airbus thales safran ou encore zodiac
aerospace plusieurs poids lourds de
l'aéronautique
installé sur l'agglomération un secteur
qui emploie treize mille personnes et
pour commencer je vous propose de
découvrir les conditions du
rapprochement entre deux entreprises de
l'aéronautique
le groupe safran et l'équipementier yves
binois zodiac aerospace les images sont
signées stéphane servant
ce n'est plus qu'une question de mois un
géant français de l'aéronautique devrait
naître d'ici la fin de l'année un projet
solidement implanté dans les yvelines
safran a décidé de racheter lib linois
zodiac aerospace une opération
financière chiffrée à 8 7 milliards
d'euros
spécialisée dans la fabrication des
moteurs le groupe safran avait déjà fait
une op à associer à une fusion en
janvier dernier une offre rejetée à
l'époque avant qu'une nouvelle
proposition soit faite au mois de mai un
nouveau format de rapprochement entre
safran et zodiac aerospace qui doit
encore recevoir les autorisations des
autorités de la concurrence qui doit
aussi recevoir les l'accord des
instances représentatives du personnel
et si tout se passe bien l'offre de
safran sera lancée en fin d'année et
aboutira concrètement au début de
l'année 2018
mais il est vrai que safran et zodiac
sont tous deux implantés dans les
yvelines
il est très probable que la plantation
dans les yvelines continuera à se
développer pour soutenir le
développement de l'industrie
aéronautique zodiac aerospace 120 ans
d'histoire depuis 2007 le groupe
focalise son activité uniquement dans
l'aéronautique
installé à plaisir c'est un poids lourd
du secteur dans les yvelines en 2016 il
réalise un chiffre d'affaires de 5,2
milliards d'euros un résultat adossé à
la production d'équipements en cabine
sièges masques à oxygène ou encore
système numérique
plusieurs outils fabriqués notamment à
plaisir un site employant mille trois
cents personnes
on montre aujourd'hui sur ce salon du
bourget une sonde de jaugeage de
carburant qui utilise la fibre optique
et qui rend les avions qui utilisent de
plus en plus de composites plus sur
cette sonde a été développé à plaisir
par nos ingénieurs en coopération avec
notre autre site de roche la molière
mais on est extrêmement fier de
présenter cette innovation qui a été
retenue par boeing pour son boeing 777 x
qui arrivera d'ici 2019 2020 dans les
investissements du futur nous
investissons sur l'avion de demain un
avion plus sûr plus économes en
carburant grâce aux nouvelles
technologies
une utilisation des innovations
technologiques préconisée par le
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre chargé du numérique
c'est impressionnant de voir le rôle du
numérique dans toutes les entreprises
qu'on a vu cet après midi que ce soit
dans les start up ou dans les grands
gros on voit qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
technologies elle passe par la mise en
oeuvre de technologies numériques qui
vont réinventer à la fois le métier
réinventer l'utilité et la vente et la
façon de fabriquer la façon de faire et
donc c'est une rêvant sur l'industrie
c'est une réinvention de ses usages
un développement qui pourrait
s'accentuer avec le rapprochement entre
zodiac aerospace et safran de nouvelles
innovations pourrait naître dans les
yvelines
moment très attendu de ce salon du
bourget les démonstrations en vol et
particulièrement la voltige aérienne
le public nombreux a pu admirer la
patrouille de france mais également ses
petits avions des caps 10 basée à saint
cyr l'école sur le terrain de l'aéro
club
ils appartiennent à laval amicale de
voltige aérienne qui a formé de nombreux
pilotes
le club possède plusieurs modèles
monoplace ou biplace et comprend une
centaine de membres à sa tête
régis alajouanine qui a créé le club il
ya 37 ans c'est une légende de
l'aviation qui fabriquent tous ses
avions à beacon lodge ariane les créée
en 1987 à 37 ans a autour d'agapes
disent qu'on a toujours avec notre avion
fétiche et depuis bain avec toute
l'équipe de bénévoles que j'ai on a fait
tout plein de choses on a re permis aux
cadres de revoler après un accident
on a fait des modifications on a fait
évoluer les câbles et on ait des avions
qui sont champions du lion du monde avec
des champions et des championnes comme
quoi le mordant qui est encore
championne du monde qui a été championne
du monde au texas avec notre carte de
332 démonstration avec ce cap 432
véritable formule un désert qui
participent au championnat du monde de
voltige aérienne
le pilote atteint la vitesse de 400 km
heure avec des accélérations de plus ou
moins 9 g soit neuf fois le poids de son
corps à son bord benoît mériaux un
pilote d'exception
ingénieur chez dassault aviation il faut
aimer se concentrer il faut aimer
des sensations assez forte fait un
certain physique aujourd'hui la
particularité c'est elle à très haute
température on va dire il faut aimer la
rigueur et il faut aimer se remettre en
question ce qui est parfois très
difficile pour l'ego le pilote très
concentré se focalise sur les figures
maintes fois répété il enchaîne les
tonneaux et les figures c'était aussi la
première démonstration en vol pour
dorine bourneton régis alajouanine a
modifié un avion pour que cette jeune
femme paraplégique à la suite d'un
accident d'avion à l'âge de 16 ans
puissent à nouveau évoluer seul dans les
airs j'ai commencé la formation de
voltige ya deux ans à peu près et
aujourd'hui j'ai atteint un deuxième
cycle de voltige et à ce titre j'ai pu
faire une démonstration de voltige ici
au projet parce que je suis la première
femme handicapée au monde pilotes de
voltige
grâce à ces modifications techniques des
commandes manuelles à la main elle peut
piloter le premier avion équipé pour une
personne handicapée
chez super pia parce qu'après avoir un
accident d'avion à l'âge de 16 ans c'est
une belle revanche
[Musique]
le secteur de la défense et de
l'aérospatiale civil ou militaire est
très fortement implanté dans les
yvelines avec des grands groupes leaders
européens voire mondiaux comme thales
safran ou airbus défense airbus defense
and space acteur majeur aux multiples
activités civiles et militaires est
implanté depuis longtemps aux mureaux
avec sa filiale qui fabrique la fusée
ariane
mais aussi à elancourt où sont employées
près de 2000 personnes principalement
des ingénieurs dans des activités
digitales chargé de la cybersécurité il
développe également des outils de
télécommunications terrestres
il fabrique des équipements spatiaux
mais aussi la conception et la
fabrication de drones des drones
aujourd'hui indispensable aux missions
de nos armées vous avez derrière moi
tous les produits drones qui sont conçus
à elancourt par nos équipes d'ingénieurs
qui pilotent notre activité drone depuis
elancourt vous avez derrière moi le
drone harfang qui est celui qui équipe
les armées françaises actuellement et
les petits drones qui sont utilisés par
l'armée de terre donc c'est une activité
qui est tout à fait d'actualité et pour
laquelle on essaie de développer un
service civil pour faire voler les
drones à des fins gouvernementales ou
d'organismes comme loana est fou avions
civils ou militaires hélicoptère lanceur
spatial
airbus va bien et l'implantation dans
les yvelines et pérenne la croissance de
ce secteur profite à l'économie locale
la fabrication de tous ses avions ses
satellites fait appel à une multitude de
sous-traitants dans le département des
petites sociétés spécialisées
indispensable acte i dig est l'une
d'entre elles cette pme de 25 personnes
est installée à elancourt et fabrique
des pièces pour les plus grands
fournisseurs
elle est présente au salon tant pour son
image que pour maintenir des contacts
avec ses partenaires industriels
elle est installée au pavillon de la
région ile de france qui compte près de
200 sociétés à sa tête un ancien de
dassault
l'entreprise fabrique des machines de
précision qui vont servir à calibrer des
pièces nécessaires pour guider des
avions civils ou militaires comme le
rafale
quand rafale ne pourrait pas assurer sa
navigation sans notre société parce que
bien entendu nos clients ce sont les
grands de la navigation
c'est des sociétés comme sagem comme
comme thales le fait d'être dans
ils encourent dans les yvelines je
dirais dans le grand paris en général
c'est que quand on regarde bien toutes
les grandes entreprises dans leurs
bureaux d'études dans leur ampleur
finalement dans leurs centres d ea de
décisions localement également vous
n'êtes pas loin des grands aéroports qui
permet de se déplacer
c'est donc tout un département avec de
nombreuses entreprises petites ou
grandes qui a été mis en valeur lors de
ce 52e salon international de
l'aéronautique du bourget le bilan de
cette édition 2010 est est très positif
pour l'ensemble du secteur plus de 150
milliards de dollars de commandes ont
été signés lors de ce salon
le salon du bourget est l'occasion pour
l'école de rencontrer ses partenaires
industriels
de nombreux anciens élèves sont
employées dans les diverses sociétés de
l'aérospatiale de l'armement et de
l'aviation
lors des journées grand public c'est
aussi le lieu pour faire connaître
l'école et susciter des vocations ou des
inscriptions à le pavillon de lézat et
le cnes par exemple qui font rêver et on
a l'occasion de parler avec les
industriels du secteur avec des
ingénieurs qui travaillent maintenant
que les gens donc c'est une bonne façon
de pouvoir voir ce qu'on pourrait
devenir dans quelques années le diplôme
d'ingénieur est assez polyvalent et
permet de travailler dans les différents
domaines du spatial ou de l'aviation une
école à la pointe des technologies pour
des métiers de plus en plus connectés
les méthodes de réalité augmentée de
réalité virtuelle de simulations
permettent aujourd'hui de calculer ce
qui auparavant ne pouvait se faire qu'en
vrai grandeur quand un avion fait son
premier vol c'est pas pour voir s'ils
volent c'est pour faire la preuve et
avec un taux de réussite de plus de 99%
que tout ce qui a été calculée simuler
auparavant et bien c'était bien juste en
fait on vient faire la preuve de tout ce
qui a été fait par le calcul la
modélisation la simulation
dès la 4e et 5e années les étudiants
travaillent avec des industriels sur des
projets comme l'euro glider une maquette
3d d'un planeur à propulsion électrique
fruit d'une collaboration des écoles et
de dassault aviation est présenté au
bourget l'implantation de l'école à
montigny le bretonneux est tout sauf un
hasard
elle utilise le réseau de la communauté
de communes et le conseil départemental
l'école est aussi partenaire de
l'université versailles saint quentin
est située à proximité d'entreprises
comme safran avec son centre de
recherche
les 250 étudiants de chaque promotion
ont peu d'inquiétude quant à leur avenir
voit qu'un étudiant une fois senti
l'estac à 80% les étudiants sont
intégré dans une entreprise avant même
d'être diplômé et dans les deux mois qui
suit le plan son diplôme maintient un
matin un score de 4 environ 90%
donc voilà et c'est des chiffres qui ne
cessent de s'améliorer depuis les trois
quatre dernières années
enfin intégrer les notions
d'environnement de réduction de la
pollution dans l'exploitation et la
conception des avions de demain seront
les vrais défis de ces futurs ingénieurs
et l'école les y prépare déjà
c'est la fin de ce numéro je vous
remercie d'avoir suivi le 7-8 dossier
tout au long de la saison
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
émissions en replay sur le site internet
ou sur l'application mobile
je vous souhaite un très bon été à tous
sur tv fier 78
[Musique]